- [Narrator] In Kassel, Germany,
for a limited time only,
there is a replica
of the Greek structure,
The Parthenon, and it's made
with over 100,000 banned books.
(upbeat music)
The ‘Parthenon of Books’
is an installation that
is part of The Document of 14 art show.
The exhibit is from
South American artist, Martin Minujín.
Her aim is to spark debate
about the issues of
censorship in literature.
To achieve that, she has collected
over a hundred thousand copies of 170
different books that
have been banned
throughout the world
through various stages of history.
The books include everything
from Mark Twain's Adventures of Tom Sawyer
to Cecily von Ziegesar's Gossip Girl.
It is not a coincidence that The Parthenon
of Books is located in this German park
as it was here that Nazi’s burned
over 2,000 books by
Jewish or Marxist writers
in the early 1930s.
The books for this project
were donated by the general public.
And once the installation is complete,
they will be handed out to visitors
with the hope of inspiring readers
for years to come.
(upbeat music)